thank you
hi hey
Tashi Duncan she's gonna turn a whole
family into millionaires
should I have a fashion line a
foundation
[Music]
you're incredible today thank you I mean
it wasn't even like tennis it was an
entirely different game
hey come hang out with us later let me
come tuck you in no let me just keep
talking
come on
how often does this happen going after
the same girl not as often as you think
we usually have different types so
you're saying I should be flattered
aren't you everybody's type
[Music]
which one of us
he's not in love with you what makes you
think I want someone to be in love with
me it's nice to see you lit up about
something even if it's my girlfriend
thank you
Art's got his coach Tashi Donaldson who
also is his wife I'm playing for both of
us Tashi
I think maybe we're disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in a salon
like me when we were teenagers when we
were teenagers hey I love you
I know
you don't know what tennis is
it's a relationship
we went somewhere really beautiful
together
I'm taking such good care of my little
white boys
I assume you planned this not this part